The pre-show marks interviews each week at this time your city station brings you an interview
with a leading figure in the arts politics or the sciences and here now to
introduce today's program is Patricia
marks film is the most popular art form of the day my guest is one of its
most distinguished in the battle critics. Mr John Simon Mr
Simon a film critic for the new leader drama critic for the Hudson your view and common
weale and author of the recent book of collected film criticism
entitled private screenings views of the cinema of the
sixty's which just I mean you're a critic of theater novels poetry
and sometimes art as well as films do you feel that film is the most vital
art form of the day.
Well I do think that because there seems to be a
great market for film because a whole new generation
of young and young middle age
consumers has grown up on film. Having film for
their very favorite and. Domestic as it were
art form the demand
has forced a lot of good talent to go into
filmmaking and a good many
people a few decades ago might have been perfectly happy to be
poets or novelists or actors or play it and so
why not have all now converged on film.
Which has come to look as a kind
of banner art form of the age
that kind of form that's flashed in fount of
the greatest number of faces presumably leading us on to
greater condition. And the it can be so then yes that film is
the central line for another. Most popular the most
meaningful to the largest number of
young people you see the film gets the criticism it deserves.
No it doesn't and films this isn't may conceivably
look easier or more difficult but at any rate different from other kinds
of criticism precisely because of the kind of people who practice it
either then the very nature of the discipline.
By which I mean that because so many
cranks on the one hand. And so many fanatical
are technological enthusiasts on film rights about
film film criticism tends to look on the one hand if it's being
written by these bohemian types as being easier and less
would be
more foolish than it actually is or if it's written by
these experts on the technological side. It made them
look at something
more cryptic arcane
difficult puzzling. But at the same time lest they warding then other kinds of because this
is just I mean and how is. Prominently featured from your
book and I could hear the first and last responsibility of the critic is to raise the
standard of motion pictures as a high brow critic that writes for
a magazine that doesn't reach too wide an audience.
How do you feel you will raise the standard of motion
pictures. Well it may be
an idealistic view but then again I don't care for any viewer that is
not idealistic.
I feel that so many of the people practicing reviewing or
criticism do it either in the spirit of supplying their readers their
newspapers with a commodity there has to be a film column it has to be filled with
eight hundred or nine hundred words.
In which case they have to be.
Client cynical and indifferent or even just plain simple minded
and discriminating or the other types
who write films this isn't out of some kind of
elaborate personal love hate or love or hate
they may have for the movies which leads them into some kind
of fantastic cation and and.
Spinning
of fancy doing the moves on paper but there are very few people
to whom. Films are extremely important extremely serious. Genuine though
and for who want the best and nothing but the best from it and I feel this
is the responsibility of any serious going to now
if his magazine does not reach many many leaders. Nevertheless if
he makes an impact on a certain number they can pass the word on
to
others copies of magazines can be biodata even passed around
in some cases.
If the articles are important enough they can be reprinted elsewhere they can come out
in book
form and eventually are the words of a serious because they will reach
a sufficient number of people but even if it doesn't he has to write with that
in mind and the end is that films have to become
better especially in Hollywood much too commercial
sloppy
girlz vulgar brainless self-indulgent.
But they are that way in other countries to the critic
has to fight this tooth and nail and let the chips fall where they may if they don't
fall anywhere that matters he must still try to send them there.
I wonder why you say this I accept the charge of being unfashionable with
satisfaction and. Even I confess
pride was this.
Well because in. Most art forms but especially in
art forms like film which. Appeal to
very widely diversified group of
people enclaves are coteries clique's.
Are formed which push a certain filmmaker a certain type
of filmmaking they'll be the camp group will like can
be underground films that will be
the young beatnik hippie type so will love the sort of
irresponsible films of original Luke God
Are there will be. Perhaps starchy
old timers who will perhaps like some old fashioned Hollywood
pictures and so on but there are definitely in in
film fashions and these fashions.
I think are the contrary of criticism they're the enemy of genuine intelligent criticism
because
they accept something that is motivation
in instead of something that is really good and
deserving and there are certain fashions that are clearly operating
now which I think are particularly if the fare such as the
God are. Vulgar which I am a opposed to very happy and proud to
be opposed
to you call God are the quintessential N.T. artist.
Why are you so violently against Gadhafi. Well.
This is something that's very hard to explain in a few words it is the
longest section of my book and even at that I think it may not be long
enough and it may still not explain the sinister in this
of this manifestation and plea enough for convincing
enough people to
perceive but. Briefly go does a man with talent
but with a minor. And the major Africans
and his kind of filmmaking consists of slapping things together is
a is a kind
of spoiled in the oldest child font on the Bill of filmmaking
who has been indulged and cosseted by the coteries. Whose idea
of filmmaking
is total improvisation total
freedom
total aimlessness except
indulging the whim of that morning's shooting I mean on Monday doesn't know what he'll do on Tuesday
on Tuesday he does whatever comes into his head when he sits down beside the camera.
And so on and I'm afraid this is the same mentality which is
responsible today for
happenings for pop art
for some kind of gross experimentation
in music with
with hideous sound and even more meaningless
silences other than actual mellow they or even anything resembling
melody and this this to me is anti art in that it tries to
substitute accident improve his
ation happening falling into
something for an activity. Namely art which to me
has to be carefully thought out.
Systematically planned
deeply felt and ex
carjack
dated but which of course also showed you those times happy
accidents Felicity's that one stumbles upon but which should not base itself
on accidents and supposes
Felicity but at the same time the daughter seems to
speak very eloquently to the young certainly of.
Much admired by the younger generation many and generation. Could this
perhaps just be a generation gap. You being over these magical age of
thirty. Yes I'm even though over the unmagical age of
forty but the fact remains that no artist
has ever been a major artist if it only addressed himself to
a certain age group.
I don't care how popular novelist was with the five year olds. Even
the twelve year olds. He did not on that basis become
post or Joyce or Dickens or told stories.
To address oneself to people between the ages of fifteen and thirty let
us say and to be enormously popular with them particularly when this group
today seems to be much more fifteen then thirty and
it's thinking and doing is not. I
think it got N.T. or even the sound indication of ones to stick supremacy.
Perhaps he's capturing or portraying something that is very much a part of the times.
Well in order to capture and portray something in a way to make a
truly artistic and truly meaningful for anyone but the group. It has
to penetrate into
the consciousness and the understanding. And the
sympathy of other groups as well a novel about the
cellar knees. That would be meaningless outside of Salaam would
not be a good
novel. A play and that would be
absolutely
irresistible to high school students but only to
high school students would not be a great player to appeal only
to a generation is not
enough exaggerating them because he feels more than generations just. To.
Pauline Kael Andrew Sarris but he is a cult among generation.
Well you see this is probably one of the minor tragedies of our culture
or civilization if we can honor them with that those terms
that the young the the charming brother sensually
family ever sponsible young have taken over the culture
industry to a very large extent and to the extent that they haven't taken it over all the
people who want to appeal to this group as a
chief consuming group have taken
over and that everything is now slanted in this American society which has
always been fanatical about the youth. Anyway. Even before that
today's various youth movements are you as being a an
absolute mono mania the American consciousness so.
With this emphasis on youth a lot of older people like Pauline Kael
like Angela says for various reasons ranging
from nostalgia to put the most benevolent interpretation on it to.
Hysteria to put a less benevolent interpretation on it will embrace
these criteria and this worship of youth
but this does not mean that the average
responsible person of forty or thirty eight or forty five would be convinced
by
them in private screenings you have a chapter called favorites and
you list eleven
favorites including an early Sliney an early and Tonio name
Bergman you know most of these all of these are fairly old films none of
them less than five years old do you feel that the most recent films
being made in the last five years or less good than have been that the good old days
are better than current
cinema no masterpieces of course don't come along every.
And sometimes they come in clusters in fact very often they come in clusters for reasons that too
complicated to go into. However. In the last few years
I've seen some most deserving films a few of which I can
name for
you which are your favorites from the last five
years without calling all of these absolute favorites. I will call
them all deserving films. Some of them more so than others for the example.
Lawrence of Abia Sundays and
see battle. Mondo
county IL past or also known as the sound of trumpets a
magnificent film as is all means other work. The fiances.
To some extent had the fire within by
Louis Malle band that survived go
solo the organizer woman in the
dunes knife in the water by the woman
Polanski to a lesser extent marriage Italian style nothing
but a
man the collector one of the few American or at least
partly American films on the list. The fascist also known as El for
the neglected masterpiece mind a masterpiece but
nevertheless love E.L.O. their life upside down to die in Madrid
the
documentary family dies to a much lesser
extent the hill. Dear Joan.
To a considerable extent Alfie to a slight extent perhaps
a Man for All Seasons and a few others of which I'm probably not thinking at the
moment. In your book you seem not to like most of the recent
for the Me and Tony on a I didn't have to get to the spirits
and read desert who are the younger or lesser known directors.
Did
you Meyer Are there any people that you see. Will gain
the stature of an
interview is sure that both the only
and Fellini have undergone a falling off since
their masterpieces leave it alone the and love into that on the other
hand Bergman the whole affair seem to be quite dormant
and less than spectacular in the
last five or six films came spectacularly to the
fore with personal note which is one of the most profound and searching in
the same time beautiful films of all time and it certainly belongs
on any list of the twenty or thirty best films and I
mean. Similarly there are
younger filmmakers who promise
well twenty four we started
out and has more the Simply
them quite poorly but a man like that could buy
Happy change of pace achieve something quite
marvelous yet on me.
O'Neill made the absolutely first rate sound of trumpets and
only slightly less spectacular The fiance is good yet
do very great things not that those who
aren't. There
are one or two young
Swedish filmmakers who look very promising Polanski was started
out with really smashing knife in the water and there's been wasting his time
on cheap horror movies may yet grow up and
into something very good. There are checks
who come is to be quite outstanding and the checks have
already
made three or four very fine movies since the last war most of which haven't
been seen here except in special festivals the ones that have. Been seen
actually are not the best films with the exception of closely watched
trains with movie of absolutely the first
thing so and again jello Pantech all of the it
was documentary The Battle of Algiers a film of major importance.
Peter Watkins with the very fine war game despite
the unsuccessful privilege quite yet to do some
important film so I don't think the picture is bleak at
all you actually haven't mentioned any American directors assess by oversight
or by.
No not that oversight it's just the only American director for whom one
really rooted over the last ten or twelve years was Stanley
Kubrick and I'm afraid despite Dr say in July which was a
very very worthy and very witty film
and important one nothing else that cool
because lately as been up to what one
expected the other filmmakers in this country are either working within the
crippling Hollywood say jacket where they have no
independence
really or are too independent by which I mean
they're underground or scattered on impoverished unsupported.
Unfortunately neither the foundations nor the state government has
any program as yet functioning
that adequately finances in the pendent filmmaking which indeed is very
expensive but there are stirrings in the
air which indicate that this may change for the better.
What about Arthur Penn and his recent film Money implied which is received a great deal of praise.
But I think I said Penn is a clever but they're effective filmic
I think Bonnie and Clyde is vastly overestimate its
technique though. Neat and sometimes quite effective
is terribly reminiscent
of playful and God. And
other novella Wagner
filmmakers. There is there is ultimately a lack
of independent imagination in the loss of a lack of first
aid creativity in them which I think prevents him from being
a major film. Because I think always
will one of the recent developments in film which is prominently featured Expo
sixty seven has been new techniques many screen
simultaneous action new forms shapes sizes of screens do you feel this
is helpful and promising in artistic
terms you know one can always tell the middle dark civic by the fact that
he leaps into prophecy.
It seems that he is bored with criticism that he likes nothing better than to put a
gnostic case about the future and they will tell you at great length that these
new media evolution eyes are film or inversely that
they cannot contribute to storytelling and will never have any role
in a feature
length story films. Thankfully I don't know what the future
holds while I care in the sense that any consumer and
then the critic must care. I don't do really care about it that Munch that I
should that i should the
deflect any great extent of my speculative energies on that other
than on judging evaluating weighing
discussing feelings through and thinking through the current films
which isn't work enough for anyone who takes criticism seriously I don't know
either there are parts in me which think that these new devices are very
interesting parts of me which think that
I cannot as yet for the life of me see how they can be put to
the service.
Film art in the sense that I understand and long.
For that.
So I frankly don't know but it's it's it's an ignorance which I think is a quite blissful
and disturbing one.
I'd like to close the interview with you reading part of a review that in
your current book private screening. Would you do
that possibly the one memorable sentence
in life double issue on the movie is read. When the
day puckers up Senegalese and Swedes feel the touch of
her
lips. As I am neither Senegalese nor Swedish The only thing
I feel and I stay Packer's up and we shall soon see
America's sweetheart without her cloak of and without her
pocket is not. Against my better judgment. I
again attempted the stomach of one of her films. Move over darling which yet again.
Affected me as a cross between an old a
sucker and the hand painted necktie. It should give us
pause that diverse day has been for years the number one box
office attraction in the American cinema.
It should start us thinking that her sickening films have been well received by the reviewers.
It should make us sit up at the reputable critic on the recent T.V. show
after knocking some of her films hastily added but this was not meant
to minimize her very real talent. The only very real talent
Miss de possesses is that of
being absolutely sanitary personality and touched
by human emotions that our UN clouded by human
thought her form and smudged by the slightest
evidence of femininity. What then does it mean that
this heavily sugarcoated as well as sugar. Skinned and
sugar
boned pill should coax the largest number of
coins from the hands of American moviegoers. From the
tiny sweaty ones of our young. To the daintily
manicured or a vet I'll leave her suit ones about
adults only by the conjoined spending of all these
hands is one anointed America's number one box office attraction.
Now the alleged virtues of Miss days Persona
three crisp with girlish radiance
and healthy sexuality. As anyone who scrutinizes even one of the
day movies will know the wit is so crisp that duct on
your head. It produces instant coma. The Radiance is
so girlish that it has to be shot through special screens that this guy's a
bad case of creeping. Which has begun to average
that once you fully incipit the
face. And the healthy sexuality is a core a protracted game
of teases and the blunt on Them's. Played between husbands and
wives or couples. Well on the way to the altar.
And with all be and beds remaining relapse
area and really solid. What I repeat does
this and then make their worship me. It means that. Two or three
generations of Americans are. Basking in with listeners and calling it with it.
In the facelessness and calling it
radiance in sexlessness and calling it sex in total
darkness and calling it there. It means that until
this sponge sugar zombie melts for the
screen there is little chance of the American films coming of age. Whatever.
Delicious shivers make course up and down the spines of
Senegal sweet.
Mr Simon thank you. My guest has been John Simon film critic for the
new leader and author of the recent book private screening. Thank
you and goodbye for
now you have been listening to Patricia Marx interviews join us again
next Friday at five when once again we bring you the pre-show marks
interviews
that
is
who think that it
was you who
think
that
if you're.